[Music]
the loud house is so popular that the
fans of the show have started
reimagining the characters in alternate
universes
you can now find the characters looking
like bodybuilders you can see them all
grown up and you can even find
illustrations of them as babies wait
until you see a baby version of Lenny
loud if you love the loud house give
this video a thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe let's check out 10 the loud
house characters reimagined as kids
Luna loud Luna loud is our favorite
she's only 15 years old but she already
has a unique style it's very much
different from the rest of her siblings
we love her rock look her purple outfits
and her constant humming of her favorite
rock songs
she's pretty fun to be around and we bet
that an 11 year old luna was exactly the
same see Bart showed that Luna hasn't
quite developed her rock style at 11
years old but even though she's not
rocking her iconic look she still looks
totally adorable in that purple dress
we have to say we didn't expect her to
have long hair at blades do you think
she cut it short hey guys we are so
excited to announce we are producing our
own original content head over to the
trendy for the best bi wives fashion
tips makeup acts and so much more we are
sure you're going to love it see you
there Lin lang wait until you see this
illustration it has to be our favorite
map the 13 year old Lin loud is one of
the most competitive characters ever she
always wants to win which often gets her
on the siblings nerves if you have a
competitive sibling you probably
understand where we found an
illustration of win reimagined is a baby
and it seems like she was even
competitive back then
this drawing belongs to Kabutops the bad
from deviantART who turned Lin into a
crying baby
we're not sure what made her upset but
we can imagine she didn't win at
something isn't a red and white shirt
just too adorable for words we bet Lin
was into sports even when she was a baby
Lincoln Lounge the 11-year old Lincoln
is the only boy in the family which can
sometimes be incredibly crazy and
frustrating at some point he even wishes
to have 10 brothers instead but
eventually realizes that having sisters
is a
better choice we found this picture
showing Lincoln as a baby boy does he
look adorable he resembles Lily the
youngest in the family but we bet his
life was slightly easier as a baby he
only lived with five other sisters and
all he had to do was crawl around in
that adorable orange onesie we bet he
never knew he'd become the middle child
and have ten other siblings Lucie loud
we loved Lucille out even though she's
sometimes quite scary with her black and
white look you can barely see your eyes
as they are covered with long bangs but
that's exactly what makes Lucie special
Kratos 93 from deviantART showed us a
much younger Lucie that doesn't really
look that scary in fact she's pretty
adorable although her actual age is
unknown this baby Lucy is already
reading a poetry book she still has long
fangs but her cute hair is now up in two
pigtails and she's carrying an adorable
teddy bear we bet she's just as moody as
the eight-year-old Lucy we can't blame
her like pretty exhausting when you're a
baby
Luanne loud let's move on to the
jokester of the family
you should always watch out for Luanne
on days like April Fool you can always
let you have something up her sleeve
although her family doesn't really like
her jokes we think they're pretty funny
this fourteen-year-old definitely has a
bright future but let's take a step back
and check her out at six years old
this illustration belongs to see Bart
from deviantART doesn't she look just as
crazy as Luanne at 14 we love how she's
still wearing her yellow outfit but is
her hair and her adorable tooth that
make her stand out we bet she was
already cracking jokes at six
Lisa loud the four year old Lisa loud is
already a baby but she's smarter than
any other member of her families if
you've watched our other videos on the
loud house you probably already saw Lisa
reimagined
body builder a boy and plenty of other
scenarios and here she is a baby Lisa
this image belongs to the talented jewel
X 93 from deviantART who did an amazing
job
baby Lisa is wearing a green shirt but
we can still see her holding her iconic
glasses and check out that green
pacifier we also love the playing blocks
itself science Lisa was really meant to
be a scientist since she was a baby
Lola loud if you watch our videos you
know we think the six-year-old Lola loud
pretty much looks like Alayna Thompson
also known as honey boo boo
this sassy pageant queen is definitely a
diva and we can't get enough of her
attitude we're pretty sure her attitude
started out when she was a baby
check her out this version belongs to
jewel X 93 from deviantART and we
absolutely love it look at those
beautiful big eyes baby Lola looks
gorgeous checking herself out in the
mirror and she already has her iconic
tiara on her head a we bet this Lola is
just as sassy as is Lola at 6 years old
lana loud and then there's Lana loud
Lola's twin sister and a completely
opposite character unlike her sister
Lana doesn't appreciate pageants
dressing up or being too girly
Lana prefers to be a tomboy and playing
in but to Lex 93 from deviantART
reimagined her is one of the most
adorable babies we have ever seen she's
even cuter than baby Lola we adore her
down over also we can't get over her
cute pigtails she's grinning and she
looks like she's full of love she was
always happy even as a baby plenty loud
the 16 year old Lenny loud is the
second-oldest sound slightly less
mean-spirited than her older sister we
love Lenny's fashionable look and iconic
sunglass
but we never saw what she looked like
when she was a baby see Bart from
deviantART did an amazing job at
portraying Lenny as a six-year-old look
at that gorgeous dream in there long
blonde hair the only thing she's missing
is a baby version of her white
sunglasses see Bart even kept Lenny's
mixed green outfit and baby buys it into
something a little bit more adorable
we're pretty sure the six-year-old Lenny
would still be fashionable and
incredibly loving toward the family
members just like the wedding a meal of
glory loud unlike a one-year younger
sister the 18 year old Laurie loud has a
slightly different character as an older
sibling she makes sure she never forgets
to let people know who's the oldest
child in the house but she's still
protective of her siblings and we bet
she was the same when she was six years
old the illustration of a six-year-old
Laurie belongs to see Bart from
deviantART who gave her a much more
relaxed look she looks the same but we
thought this Laurie is definitely not
spending much time on her phone and
talking to her boyfriend who loved her
haircut which hasn't really changed here
that's it for ten the loud house
characters reimagined as kids for more
videos like this one check out ten loud
house characters as body builders see
you next time
[Music]